sie waren bezaubernd glamourös und
eigensinnig nein eigentlich ist ein viel
zu harmloses wort exzentrisch waren sie
selbstbewusst wie nur der britische adel
es sein kann
besessen von sich und der art wie sie
die welt so witzig und so
unterschiedlich wie nur sechs schwestern
unterschiedlich sein können
über diese sechs verrückten schwestern
hat susanne kippenberger ein buch
geschrieben und konzentriert sich darin
auf das schwarze schaf unter den
schwestern auf das rote scharf jessica
mit volker roth weil jessica die starre
welt der britischen aristokratie des
letzten jahrhunderts konsequent hinter
sich ließ in die usa auswanderte und
kommunistin wurde
wir treffen susanne kippenberger in
münchen im museum villa stuck was mit
seiner frau des jegler atmosphäre etwas
vom zeitgeist versprühte zu beginn des
letzten jahrhunderts herrschte als die
geschichte der sechs schwestern begann
in den 20er jahren
dann kommt der faschismus der britische
faschismus von dem auch viele gar nicht
wissen dass es ihn gab der deutsche
nationalsozialismus der spanische
bürgerkrieg dann der kommunismus die
bürgerrechtsbewegung in den usa die
kommunistenjagd vietnamkrieg vietnam
proteste black panther alles drin was
hatten sie zu wünschen kann und zwar mit
extremen die sechs schwestern gegen ja
in alle möglichen richtungen eine
familie eine gemeinsame kindheit und
sechs unterschiedliche biografien nancy
schrieb gesellschaftsromane und wurde
zur grotte der literarischen high
society
pamela wollte als kind ein pferd werden
wurde dann aber hausfrau jänner feiert
19 29 die hochzeit des jahres mit dem
bier erben brian wollte guinness zwei
jahre später verfällt sie dem englischen
faschistenführer oswald mosley und
seiner ideologie politisch stand unity
ihrer schwester daniela in nichts nach
sie leisten nach münchen und wurde
freundin und vertraute adolf hitlers sie
trat auf parteiversammlungen auf und
wurde hitlers britische
webber blieb am adel wurde herzogin von
devonshire und züchtete spezielle
hühnerrassen jessica jedoch war die
wildeste von allen
sie liest marx und engels und will den
spanischen bürgerkrieg ziehen so
politisch unheimlich zum teil sind also
gerade die faschisten und so so extrem
die schwestern untereinander waren
politisch die waren von ihrer art her
waren sie sich teilweise total ähnlich
also die waren alle extrem entschlossen
und wenn sie sich vorgenommen hatten was
zu machen dann haben sie das
durchgezogen
also die sind ihren weg gegangen ob man
diesen weg nun sympathisch findet oder
oder politisch korrekt oder was auch
immer für mich fühlen die sich ganz
modern an als frauenfiguren
doch warum entwickelten sich die
geschwister so auseinander
susanne kippenberger beschreibt die
elitäre haltung des englischen adels die
hermetik der familie und die von den
eltern verordnete abgeschiedenheit
sechs schwestern blieben in ihrer
kindheit vor allem unter sich
die eltern mochten kein besuch die
schwestern durften auch nicht zur schule
gehen
das heißt die sind so sehr hermetisch
groß geworden und haben viel mehr
miteinander gekämpft also dieses sich
profilieren und gegen den anderen
absetzen
das war da spielt eine viel größere
rolle und das war glaube ich schon so
eine reaktion auf diese
abgeschlossenheit die haben in den
cotswolds gewohnt auf dem land also da
gab s drum herum nichts
doch innerhalb der familie zeigt sich
der tiefe riss des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zwischen sozialismus und
faschismus am anfang war es ein spaß
dieser politischen zwist ich erinnere
mich wie unity die erstaunte postbotin
dem nazi gruß und heil hitler empfingen
während ich den rotfront groß mit
geballter faust entgegen
man kann hier immer noch unitis heil
hitler und das hakenkreuz erkennen und
mein hammer und sichel die wir mit einem
diamantring eingeritzt haben doch aus
dem spiel wird ernst
19 39 das schicksalsjahr der familie
jessica wanderte in die usa aus schlägt
sich mit verschiedenen jobs durchs leben
tritt der kommunistischen partei bei
engagiert sich in der
bürgerrechtsbewegung
später profiliert sich jessica als
kritische journalistin die ihren fokus
immer wieder auf soziale randgruppen
richtet
unity hingegen kommt 19 39 auf einer
bahre in ihre heimat zurück im
scheinwerferlicht der wochenschau
kameras hitlers englische freundin ist
nach einem selbstmordversuch trauma in
der lage zu sprechen
sie war im innersten machtzirkel der
nazis gewesen
bereits der krieg zwischen england und
deutschland ausbricht will sie ihrem
leben ein ende setzen kann man
geschwister bleiben in diesem zwiespalt
großartig im ausblenden
also die haben das dann einfach
ausgeblendet das drumherum und diese
diese liebe ist geblieben
geblieben ist noch etwas anderes
jessica madworld das rote scharf die
kommunistin rebellen die kämpferin für
bürgerrechte
sie blieb die humorvollste aller
schwester so sehr dass auf ihrem
begräbnis mehr gelacht wurde als gewinn